Michael and Paul live in South Yorkshire
with a 16 year old twin Sons Levi and
Lucas they suffer from various
disabilities last summer Levi had a
seizure and fell hitting his head on a
door what I find very difficult is the
fact that they left a child with severe
autism and all his disabilities just sat
there with me waiting to be seen for a
very long time that ambulance call that
Michael and Paul made was one of an
average of 22 and a half thousand made
each day last year of course our
categorized one to four depending on
their urgency category one is
life-threatening when someone isn't
breathing say two is emergency heart
attacks Strokes things like that three
is classed as urgent and includes things
like a fool at home and four is
non-urgent we can look at a breakdown of
what calls are for what and you can see
that here and there are set targets for
ambulances to reach people depending on
the category most of those category two
as you'll see in in a second regardless
of the target across the board people
are waiting much longer than they should
be for category 1 calls the target for
an ambulance to reach a patient is seven
minutes that dotted line you can see
what it looked like in 2019 but last
year there was this big increase in that
waiting time throughout the year it was
an average of eight minutes and 30
seconds now remember this is for
patients who may not be breathing even
bigger increase to an average of 10
minutes 55 towards the end of the year
the ambulances are taking a lot longer
to come like Levi so we're having a
cluster of seizures so it was in and out
of seizure so they'd say on the phone
um is it fitting now and if it come out
of it it would get knocked to the back
of the list
over the last few months we've heard
horror stories of ambulance Bays turning
into car Parks delays I mean patients
often have to wait before they even get
transferred to a e this is what the data
tells us for December last year if four
ambulances turned up to accident an
emergency two of them had to wait more
than 30 minutes to transfer patients 25
of ambulances one in four had to wait
more than an hour and once patients are
in accident in emergency there's yet
another wait in December one in three
people across all NES had to wait more
than four hours to be assessed that's
way up on 2019 and far far above that
Target of five percent we got to the
hospital at this point levo because of
his autism was really really unsettled
screaming throwing himself about
meanwhile his head still pumping with
blood and it just come out of a seizure
as well and then we just had to wait to
be seen
each of those data points though is
someone's story someone's life Michael
and Paul have been in almost constant
contact with the NHS since Levi and
Lucas were babies that's 16 years but
they say that right now is the worst
things have ever been good boy Tom
Cheshire Sky News fernsco South
Yorkshire